aujourd'hui
je vais vous inviter à vous reconnecter
avec vos sources
avec nos sources avec la biosphère
celle qui nous abrite et dans laquelle
nous vivons
alors j'imagine que vous êtes à peu près
tout sauf et de la pression écologique
que nous sommes en train de subir
actuellement à coups de coop comme 21 et
traités sur la biodiversité
ce concept et cette conscience
écologique
mine de rien assez récente
à titre d'exemple le mot biodiversité
est apparu à la fin des années 80 je
suis né en 94
à cette époque on était en train de
lentement changer d'idée de perception
du vivant d'exploitation des ressources
naturelles vers cette pensée qu'il
fallait la préserver préserver le vivant
pour ce concept pour notre génération
est bien admis
et maintenant on regarde presque on a un
regard presque accusateur vers nos
parents à chaque fois qu'on apprend ce
que nos prédécesseurs ont pu faire sur
l'environnement cette pression
écologique beaucoup beaucoup s'en est
frais personnellement je pense que c'est
une des plus belles opportunités de
notre époque
tout simplement parce que la pression
écologique c'est le plus grand ennemi
commun de l'humanité
et avec elle s'en suit une coalition
jamais égalée à l'échelle de la planète
c'est grâce à elle qu'on a pendant la
coop 21 ou même le once planète smit
réussi à réunir autant de pays sur la
même problématique
le même sujet autour d'un même projet je
ne parle pas uniquement d'état je parle
aussi d'associations de mouvements
citoyens d'étudiants qui coopèrent à des
échelles internationale mais alors
finalement ce concept assez récent de
dettes quand même pas 10
r est déjà dans les années 70 le club de
rome
un groupe de scientifiques avait lancé
un message d alerte en publiant le
rapport de mai dos ce rapport présenté
les limites de notre croissance
si par exemple on étudie la courbe de
l'évolution du modèle mais dos
l'évolution de la population n'a pas été
démentie depuis les années 70 et on est
exactement en train de suivre le même
modèle
on n'a pas infléchi cette courbe ça
paraît logique cependant il parle aussi
des ressources la consommation des
ressources disponibles avaient été
prédit et n'a pas été démenti on n'a pas
réussi à changer notre modèle et si on
n'arrive pas à changer drastiquement
notre consommation des ressources
le modèle prédit une chute de notre
système
une chute du système de notre expansion
de notre évolution
mais cette courbe n'est pas n'est pas
unique en son genre
toutes les espèces qui un jour
envahissent leur écosystème et mettre
une pression écologique sur le système
affronte ce genre de contre coup une
régulation naturelle se fait sentir
pourquoi pourquoi alors qu'on a ces
messages deux scientifiques qui nous
préviennent et tous ses états et pays
qui s'aligne sur la même question
pourquoi n'arrive-t-on pas à faire
flancher
c'est cool on va changer notre modèle je
pense personnellement que le plus gros
problème de l'homme c'est qu'on est
immanquablement attiré vers le
développement
on a besoin on à ce besoin de se
développer d'apprendre de comprendre
d'aller toujours plus loin
mais alors quel est le bon modèle
si on veut le besoin est inhérent de se
développer vers quels mots tels modèles
doit-on aller on est comme tiraillé on a
l'impression d'être dans une impasse
sais pas vous mais moi je sors d'une
école d'ingénieur et d'un côté on a
envie d'aller vivre costa rica dans une
hutte utiliser son vélo et boire de
l'eau de pluie est ce que c'est vraiment
la solution et en même temps on se dit
que internet c'est une avancée
technologique des plus incroyables de
plus fantastique et que l'intelligence
artificielle va nous permettre de
résoudre tous nos problèmes
d'organisation et société donc
finalement nous dans nos associations
on a une forme d'enthousiastes une forme
d' enthousiasme pour le développement et
une certaine un peu on est un peu
désespéré et désabusé on sait pas si nos
actions ne connaît pas la marche à
suivre si nos actions vont avoir un
quelconque impact positif à l'envi pour
l'environnement et si je vous disais
qu'il existe une bibliothèque pleine
d'innovations cette solution qui nous
permette nous indiquer la bonne voie
vers le développement le plus
souhaitable qu'ils nous permettent de
joindre les deux bouts à la fois la
haute technologie et le développement
durable la science de pointe et le
plaisir de la contemplation du vivant
si je vous disais qu'il y avait une
bibliothèque qui nous permet de changer
notre vision du futur cette vision qui
nous bloque
qui nous contraint dans le modèle prévu
par mais dos et prédit parce que à vrai
dire actuellement nos grands héros c'est
le tout numérique le tout domotique
alors quel est le bon modèle
ce n'est pas ce genre de bibliothèques
dont je parle moi je parle de ce genre
de milieu tecla le vivant le vivant et
ses 3,8 milliards d'années de r&d de
tests d'essai d'erreur d'évolution
adaptative de la plus petite algue au
plus grand des arbres de nos vieilles
forêts du champignon dans les racines
aux oiseaux multicolores
nous sommes entourés de génie la
durabilité et tous du plus frêle au plus
majestueux sont le fruit d'une longue
évolution d'un long processus évolutif
et ont les clés et les secrets pour la
durabilité va falloir qu'on se rapproche
de va falloir qu'on apprenne de ceux
vivant et de ses champions de la
durabilité
mais quelle tâche regardez autour de
vous et demandez vous qu'est ce qui est
vivant et qui n'a pas été produit par
l'homme
rien que là aujourd'hui le vivant ne
fait plus du tout partie de notre
quotidien
comment arriver à se reconnecter avec le
vivant c'est avec eux
ces nouveaux héros qui va falloir que
qu'on va devoir idéalisé cec nouveau
héros dont va devoir devenir les élèves
avec qui on va devoir créer des
partenariats avec qui on doit faire des
symbioses pour qu'une pour qu'une
coopération se fasse et que et que notre
système soit de plus en plus résilient
cette méthodologie ça s'appelle le
biomimétisme
cette démarche c'est innover en
s'inspirant du vivant pour innover
durablement faire du bio et isme s'est
réalisé qu'un arbre est un vieux sage
qui un porte parole de toute l'histoire
de ses ancêtres de ses prédécesseurs un
message qui nous est arrivé jusqu'à nous
et qu'on devrait apprendre à écouter
imaginé un bâtiment en bâtiment avec des
fondations aussi large qu'un arbre
finalement assez assez peu large qui
peut monter aussi haut qui arrivent à se
régénérer tout seul qui arrive à capter
l'air du ciel et de la terre et de le
traiter qui arrive à déployer des mètres
carrés de panneaux solaires et tout ça
en plus biodégradables de manière
optimum mais un arbre c'est aussi un
écosystème qui abrite de la vie entre
ses racines et sous ses feuillages un
arbre c'est tout plein de coopération
résiliente dont pourrait s'inspirer
mais si maintenant on prend un peu de
distance
ça ça c'est le caillou sur lequel on vit
c'est notre écosystème à nous et une
pensée systémique et et biomimétique
nous permet de nous poser les bonnes
questions les justes question si on
regarde ce système terre le seul espace
vivant qu'on connaisse actuellement où
toute la vie vie sur cette croûte petite
croûte de quelques kilomètres dans le
sol et quelques kilomètres dans le ciel
quel est le seul entrant énergétique qui
rendent en système toute l'énergie on
peut observer que toute l'énergie
provient du soleil c'est l'énergie
solaire et ensuite ce n'est qu' échanger
flux au sein des organismes vivants et
une seule chose dans ce système est
stockée c'est le carbone et les
hydrocarbures
on est en fait la première et seule
espèce
à déstocker aussi rapidement et on en
sait grande quantité le carbone vu comme
ça on peut se poser des questions mais
on n'est pas les seuls sur cette planète
on a de la chance parce qu'on est plus
de dizaines de millions d'espèces et
toutes ces dizaines de toutes ces
espèces détiennent des clés et des
secrets pour résoudre nos problèmes
actuels
alors comment se reconnecter au vivant
ceux vivant qui arriva âgées à allier
physique sophistiqué et simplicité
d'utilisation par exemple l'albatros on
a découvert récemment que sa teinte
ces deux teintes sur les ailes n'était
pas anodin la couleur noire en eau de
l'ale permet de capter l'énergie soleil
et chauffer alors que les la couleur
blanche va réfléchir les rayons et ne va
pas autant chauffer on va avoir presque
un gradient de 15 degrés qui peut se
créer ça va lui donner de la portance
naturel jolie démonstration de physique
non bonne leçon
si maintenant on veut s'attaquer aux
bâtiments à une des plus grosse énergie
consommatrices du vivant de notes de
l'espèce humaine
on s'acharne à refroidir ou à réchauffer
nos bâtiments sur terre près de 40 % de
notre consommation énergétique dans les
villes proviennent des bâtiments est bon
on pourrait s'inspirer par exempe des
termitières qui elles sont fraîches au
milieu des déserts ou alors une autre
industrie l'industrie chimie industrie
chimique et d'une des plus
consommatrices aussi et alors comment
arriver à faire du verre à pression et
température ambiante et bien comme ces
petites des atomes et ses petits
organismes au fond de la mer qui arrive
à faire du verre et à la température et
pression ambiante
nous sommes en train de la prendre grâce
à elle ce secret longtemps caché
le bio métis est une invitation à
changer de modèle à regarder les
écosystèmes sains sont inspirés pour
comprendre leur phénomène de résilience
à comprendre que toutes les
problématiques de gestion d'énergie du
vivant sont les mêmes qu'on est en train
d'affronter actuellement pour la
transition énergétique que toute la
problématique d'optimisation sont les
mêmes qu on est entrepreneur d'affronter
ils détiennent déjà plein de solutions
je vais donc vous inviter à prendre part
à cette révolution de la pensée à
prendre part à ce nouveau paradigme de
penser et à vous diriger vers ce nouveau
modèle de développement
celui du vivant
trouverez-vous à la curiosité du vivant
ne considérait plus uniquement le vivent
comme un phénomène comme un potentiel
d'exploitation des ressources naturelles
ou comme une nécessité de préservation
mais faites en votre partenaire faites
en votre partenaire et rouvre et votre
curiosité aux vivants et posez-vous plus
régulièrement la question comment aurait
fait vivre
comment fait le vivant pourquoi telle
forme
pourquoi telle espèce pourquoi est-elle
apte plutôt qu'une autre
pourquoi ce mutel de cette façon
pourquoi cette forme
pourquoi s'en sort-elle en hiver et se
réveille tel en printemps qui cohabite
avec elle qui prend soin d'elle 2 qui
prend l soins comment gère-t-elle ses
ressources
tant de questions qui peuvent nous
donner temps de réponse incroyable
je vais donc vous inviter à reprendre la
chemin des forêts le chemin dans les
parcs ou les mêmes le muséum d'histoire
naturelle ces petites rencontres avec
les coccinelles sur la table de votre
jardin à le partager avec votre famille
et vos enfants et leur présenter ses
nouveaux héros
le héros de durabilité al noura leur
présenter ses nouveaux maîtres à penser
et avec eux vous amuser à redécouvrir
toute la connaissance que peut nous
donner le vivant
je peux vous assurer qu'en plus d'être
intellectuellement riche et fort de
nombreuses découvertes
vous allez vite retrouvez votre âme
d'enfant émerveillé par le vivant son
génie sa magie et son incroyable talent
merci
[Applaudissements]